RACHEL: Today, we have
Beth Greer joining us here
in San Francisco.
It's very exciting.
To give a little bit
of intro about Beth,
I met Beth through
a mutual friend.
And her book, which is
called "Super Natural Home"
is what we're going to
be talking about today.
And I couldn't put it down.
It was actually quite
riveting how many things that
I had in my own house
or that I put on myself
or would eat that actually
were not that healthy in most
circumstances to even
have in your home.
So I am really excited
to bring Beth here today.
And she's going to talk about
her book, like I mentioned,
and help us understand
what we bring into our work
environment, our bodies,
and our home that matter
and to be healthy.
So we'll hear her
ultra-practical advice
on what you can do today to
limit exposure to chemicals,
toxins, what I like to call
icky things and, in general,
the things that just aren't
safe for your health, home,
or person.
So without further ado,
please welcome Beth.
BETH GREER: Thank you, Rachel.
[APPLAUSE]
BETH GREER: So every one of
you in this room already knows
a lot about going green.
I mean look at the company
you're working for-- Google.
How incredible.
They have an amazing
recycling program.
And they have solar panels.
And they feed you amazing
food, organic food
sourced from local forms.
That's fantastic.
How many of you are
eating organic at home?
OK, good.
And how many of you are
driving energy-efficient or
fuel-efficient cars
or biking to work
or maybe taking
the rail or ferry?
Yay!
Well, that's fantastic.
So I think that there's
a missing shade of green
though, because energy
efficiency is great.
Reducing your carbon
footprint is amazing.
But there's this missing shade.
And I think that it's avoiding
the chemical toxins that we're
all exposed to in our food,
in our everyday products that
might be actually
making us sick.
So I wanted to read
something to you.
I think you might
have seen it here.
And I would love
to get some input
and get your opinion about
what you think of this.
For the first time in
the history of the world,
every human being
is now subjected
to contact with
dangerous chemicals
from the moment of
conception until death.
So when do you think
that was written?
AUDIENCE: Rachel Carson.
BETH GREER: Yes.
So would you believe it's
not written recently?
And you know.
It was written in 1962,
over 50 years ago,
by Rachel Carson, who's the
author of the book "Silent
Spring," which
she's the forefront
of the environmental movement.
And what's happened
in the last 50 years?
Well, it's actually
gotten worse.
There are about 80,000
chemicals on the market today,
manufactured today.
And we are exposed to, on
average, about 6,000 of them.
And the kicker is that
only a very small fraction
have been tested for safety.
Think about our health
crisis right now.
How many of you know of
people who have diabetes?
What about people
who were diagnosed
with cancer this year?
So almost all of us, right?
There are scientific
studies that
are proving that these chemicals
are impacting infertility.
And they're hormone disruptors.
They're causing girls to
go into puberty early.
It's really disturbing.
The autism rate alone.
Just in the past 10 years,
autism has increased by 78%.
So really, what is going on?
These chemicals
can make you feel
sleepy and grumpy
and itchy and sneezy.
How may of you ever felt like
one of the seven dwarfs, right?
So in my case, it started with
a sharp pain in my shoulder.
And I remember this.
It was 11 years ago.
I was in Maui in December 2002,
enjoying the beautiful climate.
And this pain came
out of nowhere.
And when I came
back to this coast,
I went to my chiropractor
to see what was going on.
And he suggested I get an MRI.
And this is what
was in my chest.
Not a tennis ball,
but it was a tumor.
It was this big.
Imagine having that inside you.
And I just thought, how
did this happen to me,
when I was doing
everything right?
I thought I was leading
a healthy lifestyle.
I ate well.
I exercised.
I watched my weight.
I didn't smoke.
I even had a
meditation practice.
So how could this happen to me?
So I went to three top surgeons.
And they all wanted
to remove it.
They scanned it.
And it was benign.
But they said that this
thing could turn cancerous
at any moment.
And so one wanted to cut
me under my collarbone
to get it out.
The second one wanted to
cut me under my armpit.
And the third wanted
to go in from the back
and remove one of my ribs.
Well, they couldn't agree
on how to remove it.
But they all agreed that
it was risky surgery,
that I could lose the feeling
in my hand permanently.
And so I just thought, I need
to just stop for a moment
and just figure this out.
And I got quiet.
I took a breath.
And I just asked for guidance.
And what came to
me was simplify.
So I thought, OK,
what can I simplify?
What is the easiest thing to do?
And it's the food
that I was eating.
We all eat three times a day.
We have the most
control over that.
And so I looked at
what I was eating.
Even though I thought
I was eating healthy,
I was eating processed food.
I was eating out a lot.
We don't know what's
in our restaurant food.
And so I just decided to do
something kind of radical
and eat food without any
product labels whatsoever.
And I went on a juice cleanse.
And you know what?
In just three days,
the pain that I was in,
which was really considerable,
started going away.
And that was remarkable to me.
And I just thought, wow,
I'm on to something here.
What else can I simplify?
And so I took a look at what
I was putting on my skin,
because our skin is not the
barrier that we think it is.
It allows in
microscopic chemicals.
And I looked at my
deodorant, my shampoo.
And I'm going to talk
about some of this.
There was a paragraph worth
of ingredients on there.
So I switched out
to all natural.
And then I decided
to look at what
I was surrounding myself with.
Our household cleaners
are really toxic.
And I'm going to share that
with you in a little bit too.
Switched out to all natural,
got a natural mattress.
And six months-- it took me six
months-- the pain went away.
And six months later, I
had this tumor scanned.
And it had disappeared.
It disappeared.
It was life changing for me.
It was just such a
life-changing moment
to realize that our bodies
are self-healing organisms
if we get out of the way and
feed them natural products
and put natural
products on our skin
and clean with
natural products, just
become as natural as possible.
So I am going to share with
you some things on this table.
And my promise is
that by the time
you leave here today that
you're going to really come away
with feeling empowered
and confident in choosing
natural safe products,
even though some
of the information I'm going to
tell you is a little bit scary.
So let's talk about
Brad for minute,
because this is-- one of
the things I love to do
is I just go into the
stores and buy stuff
that the average
person is buying.
And so what do you think the
shelf life of a loaf of bread
should be?
Should be.
AUDIENCE: A week?
BETH GREER: A week.
Three, four days, right?
OK.
So if I have to tell
you, and I wrote it down.
This was purchased
February 21, 2013.
I bought these two
loaves of bread.
It is now November 2013.
And it is as squishy
as the day I bought it.
It's not been in my
refrigerator or my freezer.
It's been sitting
out in my pantry.
There's no mold on it.
So this contains
something that you
need to pay attention to--
calcium propionate, which
is a preservative.
And when they feed it
to laboratory animals,
it causes them to
have ADHD behavior.
So it sounds funny.
But it's really kind of sad.
And so an easy switch
would be to buy
bread that doesn't have
preservatives in it.
And so maybe you have to
freeze it or refrigerate it.
It will save your health.
OK.
Then I went into the store.
And there's this
blueberry muffin mix.
And it says right on the label,
right on the front cover,
it says artificially flavored
with imitation blueberries.
And I thought, what?
What could be in here that could
make artificial blueberries?
Do you have any thoughts?
What?
AUDIENCE: Raisins.
BETH GREER: Raisins?
That would be a
healthy choice, right?
OK.
So I'm going to tell you--
hydrogenated lard, partially
hydrogenated lard, hydrogenated
soybean and cottonseed oil.
So first of all, when
you hydrogenate an oil,
it creates trans fats.
And it causes heart disease.
So we're feeding
this to our children.
I had given a talk.
And this woman said, I
just made that for my kids.
And she didn't notice,
because it was in small print.
She didn't notice it was
artificial blueberries.
How hard would it
be to just throw
in some natural blueberries
or some raisins?
This also has three
artificial colors.
So I want to just tell you
about artificial colors.
They're banned in Europe.
But they're sold
here in America.
So why are they
banned in Europe?
Because they've done studies
on artificial colors.
And normal children who
were given these colors
had temper tantrums,
anger issues.
So we might be unsuspectingly
feeding ourselves and our kids
this stuff that
really shouldn't be.
Here's Fruity Pebbles.
This is gluten-free.
So people are looking
for a gluten-free option.
They think it's healthy.
But this is also made with
hydrogenated oil, which
I found shocking
that children are
given this hydrogenated oil.
And it's got four colors in it.
The other thing
this has in it is
9 grams of sugar in a serving.
So 9 grams of sugar
is a tablespoon.
OK.
3/4 of a cup is a serving.
I don't know about you.
Most people pour in a big bowl.
They're not just eating 3/4 of
a cup, which is about this much.
So you're getting a big
dose of stuff in here.
And so then I thought,
OK, well this one
looks healthy-- Fiber One.
It's got 60 calories per
serving, got a lot of fiber.
But it has zero sugar.
So I thought, well, what
are they sweetening it with?
Aspartame.
So aspartame is found in Equal.
This is the same thing.
Now, in case you didn't know,
aspartame they're saying
can be a neurotoxin.
It can really mess
up your brain.
And so one of my
clients, I remember,
she got a packet of Nestle's
hot cocoa mix in the mail.
But it was a low-calorie one.
And she drank it.
And she had a dizzy spell.
Didn't really think
anything of it.
And the next day
she had another cup.
And after that, she had
another dizzy spell.
And so she looked at the
thing, and she saw aspartame.
So she started to
connect the dots.
And then about a week later,
she went to a restaurant.
And she ordered a
slice of pecan pie.
And when she got
up from the table,
she had another dizzy spell.
And so she asked
the chef, excuse me,
what did you sweeten
your pecan pie with?
And he said, oh, Equal.
So she was smart.
She was able to
connect the dots,
because other people
have dizzy spells.
And then what happens?
They go get anti-dizzy
medication from their doctors.
When in actuality, the
simple thing is just
start reading the labels and
avoid things like aspartame.
This Crystal Light
contains also aspartame.
And it's got two colors in it.
Do you drink Crystal Light?
AUDIENCE: No.
I'm just thinking about
people eating lunch.
It surprised me.
BETH GREER: Oh my goodness.
So let's see.
What else can I talk about here?
Here, Dr. Pepper, this
is Diet Dr. Pepper.
Also, this has aspartame in it.
I just find it alarming.
My teenage daughter had
this in her backpack.
And I said, rather
even that you had
sugar rather than just this.
And then to pay attention
to, for example,
this Vitamin Water.
They have the servings.
There's 2 and 1/2 servings
in this container.
So if you're
drinking it, thinking
this is kind of
healthy for you, you're
getting the equivalent of a can
of Coca-Cola in terms of sugar.
So this has 13 grams
of sugar per serving.
But this is 2 and 1/2 servings.
So you multiply that.
You're getting 39
grams of sugar.
That's astonishing.
And you think it's healthy,
because it's vitamin.
I see shock in the audience.
And then this one, popcorn.
This also has--
AUDIENCE: God, that looks bad.
BETH GREER: It looks bad?
Partially hydrogenated--
AUDIENCE: What's the story?
BETH GREER: It's got the
partially hydrogenated
vegetable oil in it.
So we make our own
popcorn at home.
So easy.
I use coconut oil in a pot
and heat it up-- delicious.
So does anyone
have any questions?
First, I've talked
about what goes in us.
Right.
Well, those are OK.
You just have to see what the
artificial-- is it artificially
sweetened?
And is it artificially colored?
So that's what you want
to pay attention to.
But the electrolytes are great.
And yes, doctors are not
trained in nutrition.
They get a couple of hours
in their years of study.
And so they don't know about
this for the most part.
People like Dr. Oz are now
starting to talk about it.
But it is kind of controversial.
But I really think we
really need to pay attention
to this, because this can
really impact your health.
And I think the number
one thing to think about
as a takeaway on the food
thing is to really try
to avoid processed
foods, because that's
where you're going to get
all the sugar, the coloring,
the additives, the
flavorings, and also
the genetically modified foods.
If you're concerned about
that, probably 80% to 90%
of our soy and cotton--
cotton too-- but soy and corn
are genetically modified.
And I know there's
pediatricians that
are taking that these
kids who-- there's
a big influx of problems
with their bellies now.
They're getting diarrhea and
constipation and all this.
When they take them off
the GM foods, they heal.
Their gut heals.
And it's all that stuff that
is sneaked into these breakfast
bars.
Like here, this
Kashi, for example.
It has no high fructose
corn syrup, which is great,
because they figured
out the buzz word,
because they know
people, like, oh, I
don't want to eat high
fructose corn syrup.
So it makes it look
like it's healthy.
But this has GM soy in it.
It's Roundup Ready.
Anyway, something
to pay attention to.
Yes?
Well, no, Splenda is
highly, highly processed.
And it can be a
migraine trigger.
And Sweet 'n Low I'm going
to talk about in a second.
And then Stevia is great.
It's made from a plant.
So you need to look for--
AUDIENCE: And agave
as well is good.
BETH GREER: Agave is
good, yeah, and honey.
All those natural
sweeteners are great.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: How do
you feel about meat?
BETH GREER: About what?
AUDIENCE: Meat.
BETH GREER: Meat.
Oh, well, eat meat.
I only eat meat that's pasture
raised, organically grown,
that sort of thing, because
the beef industry notoriously
injects their cattle
with growth hormones
and antibiotics and all that.
So if you're going
to eat meat-- I
can't tell you one
way or another.
But it works for my body.
But I make sure that my
chicken also is pasture raised.
I get a little bit neurotic
when I go into a restaurant.
It's like, where's
your meat from?
And is your wine biodynamic?
And what kind of oil are
you using on your salad?
I mean you can go a little nuts.
But I go with the 80/20 rule.
80% of the time I feel
like I try to do my best.
OK.
So plastic bottles.
The number one, like these
Crystal Geyser bottles,
apparently don't leech
any kind of harmful,
they say, I don't know
for sure, but they
say they're pretty safe.
But they're meant
for a single use.
A lot of people reuse them.
And that can be a problem,
because you're also
getting bacteria.
You can reinfect
yourself with bacteria.
The hard plastic
bottles contain BPA.
Now, there's been this
whole controversy about it.
And you'll see a lot of
bottles that say BPA free.
However, they're using BPS now.
So it's an untested chemical.
So you think it might be safe.
So the safest thing, what I do
is I use a glass water bottle.
And I fill up.
So as long as we're
talking about water,
we should talk
about our tap water.
The Associated Press did a study
on our tap water in America
and discovered that there
is pharmaceutical drugs
in significant quantities
in our tap water.
So antidepressants, birth
control pills, hormones,
Viagra, all that stuff,
we're drinking all that.
So I recommend getting a
filter on your home tap
and then using either a
glass or metal bottle.
And then you should
be good to go.
OK.
So I'm going to move
on to what goes on us.
So we were talking a little
bit about the Sweet 'n
Low, which is saccharine.
So I went into my store.
And I was looking at toothpaste.
And every single
toothpaste I could
find, except a natural one,
like Tom's, for example,
contains saccharine.
Saccharine is an
artificial sweetener.
So they've done studies
on laboratory animals.
And they've discover that
when you give these animals
saccharine, they
develop bladder cancer.
So I'm not saying that
you brush your teeth--
I remember my daughter had
a sleepover with this girl.
And the girl goes, oh, well,
what kind of toothpaste
do you use?
Because she had a
natural toothpaste.
And then my daughter
says, what are you using?
Crest.
Don't you know that
could kill you.
So I go running in there.
No, no, no, your toothpaste
is not going to kill you.
But my message is to
really-- it takes time.
Look, I was 50 when
I got my tumor.
So this is over time.
And the good news
is that we have
so many great,
great products that
are healthy now that
are on the market
that we didn't have before.
So I use Coral White.
I love this toothpaste.
It's made from sea coral.
And then this one.
I like this Eco-DenT.
It's just baking
soda toothpaste.
It's fantastic.
It works just the same.
And you're not getting
exposed to the saccharine.
And then another toothpaste, I
just wanted to share with you,
Colgate Total has triclosan in
it, which is an antibacterial.
And it's also a pesticide.
So for example, this
Dial antibacterial soap,
the number one ingredient
on here is triclosan.
So we don't need
to use triclosan.
Bottom line, all the
doctors are saying
that the best way
to wash your hands
is to use regular
soap and water.
And when you're
using this, you're
going to develop
antibiotic resistance.
So if you do need an antibiotic,
it could be really dangerous
for you to use this stuff and,
especially, when you're putting
it in your mouth, because let's
say if your gums are bleeding
or it's going under your
tongue into your bloodstream.
So you want to just choose the
most natural, safest product.
So let's see what other
goodies do I have?
Yeah.
You can use these
sanitizing gels.
They're great.
I like EO or Clean Well.
These are all natural,
made with essential oils.
Let me just talk to you
about labeling for a minute.
So I always tell people to
look for the fewest amount
of ingredients on a label.
So this bottle of
Listerine looked great.
It only has four ingredients--
eucalyptus, thyme, menthol.
What could be so bad?
And then in the fine
print it says, peel here.
And so then when
you peel this back,
this is where all your
other stuff comes in.
So it's got 26.9% alcohol.
It's a little crazy, right?
So alcohol actually
dries out your mouth
and can give you more cavities.
They want you to just keep
using it and using it.
And also they've done
studies on people
who rinse their mouth with
alcohol-based products.
And it can give
you mouth cancer.
So it's just better to go
with something natural.
My favorite thing now is
this healthy gum drops
from Living Libations.
And I put some on a toothbrush.
It's just essential oils.
And it's just fantastic.
And I don't even
use the sudsy thing.
You just have to get used to not
having the suds in your mouth.
But I love it.
Let's see, deodorant.
Well, looking at this
one, this Ban roll-on,
it only had one
ingredient on there.
So that surprised me.
And it's aluminum.
Now, they're linking
aluminum to Alzheimer's.
And so that's not really great.
But I thought, well, how can
this only have one ingredient?
And there's no peel here label.
So I'm standing there in
Walgreen's picking away
at this thing.
And then when you
pull it back, there
are all your other-- a paragraph
worth of preservatives,
additives, fragrance.
So let me talk to you a
little bit about fragrance.
The word fragrance on
a label can mean up
to 100 different
synthetic ingredients.
It's the manufacturer's
catch phrase
that they can just
say fragrance.
They don't have to
say what's in there.
The thing is that with all
of this stuff, our bodies--
it's like taking in so much.
It's the food.
It's the chemicals in
the bread and the cereal
and the toothpaste and then the
skin care and the deodorant.
It creates this burden.
And some of the chemicals
that were tested
were only tested alone.
They weren't tested in
relation to the rest.
So it creates this
body burden on us.
And I'm convinced that that's
how I got rid of this tumor
by clearing out my
body, not having
these chemicals on there,
not exposing myself to it.
And then my body healed.
And I believe that everybody
can feel better if they just
switch to natural things.
This is one.
This is produced in Canada.
And so it says,
drug facts, which
I thought that was fascinating,
because it is a drug.
These are drugs.
That's the thing.
We're not really
getting the picture.
These chemicals are drugs.
They interact like drugs.
And this one, again, peel
back and you see all the stuff
in here.
Now, Tom's for
example, well, this
should be safe and natural.
But the number one ingredient
on the stick deodorant
is propylene glycol.
Does anyone know
where that comes from?
Antifreeze.
So it's a penetration
enhancer they call it.
So when you put it on,
they want all the stuff
to go deeper into your skin.
So think about that.
Maybe you're shaving
under your armpits.
And then you put this on.
And you wonder, why is there so
much disease and breast cancer?
This could partially be
responsible for that.
What I use is baking soda.
I like this one, this pure
Bob's Red Mill baking soda.
And I put it in my salt shaker.
And I just sprinkle
it on my hand.
And it works 100%.
It's amazing.
Grandma was right, right?
I have a client in
Southern California.
And she's a yoga instructor.
She does Ashtanga yoga.
And she sweats a lot.
And she said, oh,
I can't do that.
I'm always reapplying
my deodorant.
I said, well, just try it, OK?
And she did.
And she's a believer now.
And she's so happy.
So it's really cool.
And then another
thing to be aware of
are these aerosols, because
they contain hydrofluorocarbons.
And they eat away
at the ozone layer.
So this one contains that.
It contains fragrance, which we
talked about; propylene glycol,
which we talked
about; and triclosan.
It's got a big punch in here.
It seems so innocuous.
I grew up with Right Guard
and Secret and all this stuff.
So just something
to be aware of.
So let me talk a little
bit about makeup.
I know that that's an issue for
people and curious about it.
And so some of the mascara
contains mercury in it,
for example.
We don't want that on our eyes.
Some lipsticks contain
lead, which we don't want.
So I love this one company
called Peacekeeper Cosmetics.
They make a wonderful
lipstick and lip balms.
And they have a
great philosophy,
where they give
back their proceeds
to urgent women's issues.
And so that's great.
And I like Jane Iredale.
Let's see.
This is Aveda, which I think
is pretty clean as well.
So Chapstick contains parabens.
And that surprised me.
And parabens are found
a lot in our makeups
and our personal care products.
And those are preservatives.
They're antimicrobial
preservatives.
And so they've done studies.
And they've found parabens
in breast cancer tumors.
So it's so simple these days to
find a great, natural products.
Well, they can be an irritant.
I don't think they're
necessarily cancer-causing.
But they can be an irritant.
There's a great website
called Skin Deep.
And it's part of the
environmental working group.
And you can go and
look at your products
and see what you're using
and then how it stacks up.
Another great
nonprofit is the Center
for Environmental Health.
They have some great
suggestions as well.
It does allow in the
microscopic chemicals.
So things like nanoparticles
you have to really pay attention
to, because nanotechnology
was designed initially
in the medical arena to allow
certain drugs and things
to help cancer
patients and like that.
But now, they've decided
to put it in our makeup
and in our moisturizer and in
our sunscreen, for example.
So Jergens has an
ultra-healing moisturizer.
And you think that it's healthy
because it says healing.
I wanted something
to heal my skin.
But It's got two parabens
in it and fragrance.
And then it's got 10
unpronounceable chemicals
in here.
You can use a simple thing
like coconut oil on your skin
as a great moisturizer.
There's jojoba oil.
I have recipes in
my book to tell you
how to make some
easy stuff like that.
I think a great thing
to do is to wear
a hat if you're sensitive.
I like to get at least a half
an hour of sun on my body
if I can because
of the vitamin D,
because vitamin D is
so critical for health.
But just make sure you're
looking for a natural sunscreen
if you do decide to use it,
something that's non-toxic.
And again, you can go to the
EWG site and look that up.
And I also have a recipe in my
book for a natural sunscreen
actually made with vitamin C.
It doesn't act as a barrier.
But it actually
goes into the skin
and protects you from burning.
And I've used it in Hawaii.
I've used it on my
little daughter.
And it works great.
OK.
So let's go on to
what surrounds us.
Well, let's talk about
household cleaners.
So this is Windex.
It says it kills
99.9% of bacteria.
And then it's got
active ingredients,
which is only 0.18%.
And then the inactive
ingredient is 99.82%.
What does that mean,
inactive ingredient?
Does anyone have an idea?
They're not telling us
what's in here, basically.
They don't have to buy law.
I know that there
are some senators who
are trying to work on
getting these manufactures
to tell us what's in here.
But basically, 99% of this
stuff we have no idea.
But I do have an idea.
On the back, it says,
precautionary statement.
Hazardous to humans
and domestic animals.
So why would anybody want
to use this in their home
to clean if it's hazardous?
It makes no sense.
And one of my clients, he said
to me, oh, well, we use this.
But it's just vinegar, because
it says vinegar on the bottom.
He thought this
was just vinegar.
And it's like, no, this
is not just vinegar.
Keep out of reach of children
and pets right on the back.
This is not just vinegar.
But what I do use,
which is really great,
is vinegar and hydrogen
peroxide to clean with.
I put just plain old
hydrogen peroxide.
It costs like $1 a
bottle and white vinegar.
And then I spray
down my countertops,
my wooden countertops,
whatever, alternate.
And it kills 99.9% of e.
coli, salmonella, bacteria,
everything that
this Windex does.
And it's pennies.
And it's nontoxic.
You don't have to worry about
your pets or your children.
So how great is that?
And if you don't like
the smell of vinegar,
try some essential oil.
I like this.
Well, this is lavender
from Mountain Rose.
Just make sure it's
100% essential oil.
Because sometimes
a product might
say made with essential oil.
So those two words,
made with, that
could mean there's
only one drop,
let's say, of
essential oil in there.
So you really want to
just pay attention.
And that goes for everything.
For bread, this one
says 100% whole wheat.
Some breads will say
made with whole wheat.
And that can mean just
a small percentage.
So let's see.
And then candles,
scented candles.
One of my clients
had a chronic cough.
And for two years, she
was on cough medicine,
cough suppressant.
The doctors didn't
know what was going on.
So she said to me, when I go
to a hotel, it's so funny.
I don't cough.
And I just thought,
OK, well, there's
something in your house.
And I walked into her
bedroom and went [COUGHS].
It was already like this.
And she had these scented
candles everywhere.
And she used scented
hair products.
And I said, look, you've got
to get rid of this stuff.
And we got rid of it.
And her cough went away.
Then you tell your
doctor, right?
But this too.
This also has the
peel here label.
And it has lots of information
about it and additives.
I can smell this without
even ever opening it.
I can smell this.
So what I like to do is I
go to the farmer's market.
And I love to buy just beeswax
candles with natural cotton
wicks.
Have you seen those wicks
that have metal in there?
So they make the
candle burn longer.
But you know what that metal is?
It's lead.
It's lead, right?
So we're breathing that in.
So if you have a home with
lots of these candles,
if you look on the ceiling,
I've seen soot up there.
It's getting in our lungs.
So that's not a good thing.
And let's see.
Room spray.
I love to just use
just a regular--
this is an organic
hydrosol of rose.
And this is just lovely instead
of using those air fresheners.
They've done studies
with people who
use air fresheners in the home.
And the children have
upper respiratory problems.
Let's see.
And then, I guess,
lastly I wanted
to just talk about the
electromagnetic fields.
Just briefly, we are being
bombarded with these fields
that you can't see them.
But if we could, I saw
a documentary once.
It's like we're living with
this mesh in front of us.
So I really recommend that
you unplug your Wi-Fi at night
when you go to sleep,
because when you're sleeping,
you really want to rejuvenate.
And that's the
best time to do it.
If you're sensitive
to these things,
the Wi-Fi, in particular,
if you'd shut it off,
it would be great.
Take your electronics out
of your bedroom altogether.
That would be the
best thing to do.
Also, any sort of a unit, like,
for example, one of my clients,
her son had headaches
for two years.
And I went into his bedroom.
And he had a giant air purifier
right next to his headboard.
So I said, why do
you have this here?
And she says, well,
he's allergic.
But I use this meter that
I have, this gas meter.
And I measured.
And the field coming off
of this thing was enormous.
And I just moved
it 10 feet away,
because it drops
off very quickly.
And the next morning, the
mom called me up and said,
his headache is gone.
Do you think I gave
him a brain tumor?
I'm just so worried.
And it's like, no,
but this is something
that you just need
to pay attention to.
Or there was the home
I went into where
the baby wasn't sleeping.
And the crib was
up against a wall.
And I said, what's on the
other side of the wall?
And there was a giant
refrigerator there
that was giving
off a huge field.
So we moved the
crib across the way.
And the baby slept
really great after that.
So I know that some
of this information
may seem overwhelming
or that you're not
going to know where
to go from here.
And I found myself,
in 1987, halfway up
a 100-foot cliff in Joshua
Tree National Monument.
I was on an Outward
Bound Exhibition.
And I really thought
I was so happy,
because I got halfway up.
And I really wanted
to come down.
And I'm an ex-New Yorker.
And going up that
high, I've only
been up elevators to
high-rise buildings.
So I really wanted to come down.
And the guy who was down below
with the ropes belaying me,
he said, look, just pull
yourself up three inches,
stand on your tiptoes.
And you'll see a whole
new set of possibilities
may open up to you.
And I thought, well, that's so
profound being on this cliff
and hearing this.
And so I did.
I stood on my tiptoes.
And I saw another hand
hold and foot hold.
And I got up to the top.
And I was just
ecstatic about it.
And I thought, I'm
going to remember
this the rest of my life.
And so I just wanted to share
that with you that if you're
feeling a little
overwhelmed or not
knowing where to
go with this, what
are your three inches for you?
Maybe it's just changing
your bread or your lipstick
or your household cleaner.
Pick one thing that
you can do that you
feel that will have an impact.
And you'll see that
over time you'll
be healthier and
happier and greener.
And it will be great.
And look, we're all
in this together.
So let's work together.
And I'm here to support
you if you need coaching.
I do in-home coaching.
And I do some consulting.
I can do things by Skype even.
So let me know if
you need my help.
I'm here to do that for you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
And are there any
more questions?
It's on Amazon.
And also on my
website, BethGreer.com,
you can go there.
And I have a free
assessment for people
who want to find out how you
might be unwittingly being
exposed to these
chemical toxins.
You can fill that out.
And you'll be in the know.
You'll know what to avoid.
Well, there are instruments
that you can purchase.
And one of them is
called a Gauss meter.
And one of them is an RF meter.
It measures the fields
from computers and Wi-Fi.
And the third one-- you actually
need three, unfortunately--
is a dirty electricity meter
called a Stetzer meter.
I have information about
those on my website as well.
Farmers' markets are
really a great resource.
I like to go at like
just a quarter to 1:00.
If the farmers' market
is from 8:00 to 1:00,
I get there 15 minutes before.
They're giving away
bags of broccoli for $1.
It's fantastic.
They have something called
CSA, community-supported
agriculture.
And they deliver
boxes to your home.
They may even have
it here at Google,
where you can share
in those things.
Plant a garden for yourself.
Yes, eating meat that is
pasture raised but maybe eat
less of it.
But I also think that
you're going to save money
in the long one with
health care costs.
I don't see doctors anymore.
How expensive would
that surgery have
been for me and then the
rehabilitation and the pain
killers and all that.
And I really think you
can't buy health like this
to feel so good.
I'm 61 right now.
And I feel so much better and
more energetic and younger
than I did 10, 20 years ago.
I know it's the food.
People ask me, what do
you put on your skin?
It's what I'm not putting on
my skin that makes it glow.
Thank you, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]